What is this community like?
70% Are Latino and
African-American.
It's a working class community.
How hard is it to
get people in a town
like this motivated to
take on something this big?
There are amazing people
that I have met here
that maybe have not
ever been a part
of a campaign in their lives.
Have never spoken publicly,
have never knocked on doors,
and they're doing it.
It's almost like
everyday people have
to learn how to be activists.
Absolutely.
AMERICA FERRERA:
(VOICEOVER) Christine
says that while a big part
of the Beyond Coal strategy
is to encourage locals
to lead the charge,
talking only about climate
change isn't enough.
In this community,
the potential health
impacts are more of a concern.
And Christine says I'll
understand why if I meet Dulce
Ortiz, who lives and
works downtown just
a stone's throw
from the coal plant.
Wow.
Oh wow.
That's right outside
your window, huh?
Yes, it is.
What's that like?
It's frustrating
and inspiring,
but mostly frustrating.
AMERICA FERRERA:
(VOICEOVER) Dulce
tells me she's worried about
the health impact the pollution
from the plant might have on
her 14-year-old son, Ivan,
and her mother Sonya
who also lives in town.
So what are some of the
personal impacts that the coal
plant has had on you guys?
You've developed
similar issues.
Yes.
Is this something that is more
widespread in the community,
or is this just your family?
No, it's in the community.
It's bad.
Of course we can't
say that asthma
is caused by the coal plant.
But the pollution that's
being put out into the air
creates the asthma attacks.
AMERICA FERRERA:
(VOICEOVER) Dulce
explains that such attacks
are common in Waukegan.
One study found that one
in three schoolchildren
had asthma or asthma-like
symptoms-- a rate
far higher than in
the rest of the state.
But before meeting
Christine, Dulce
didn't even realize what the
plant outside her window was.
You didn't know
there was a coal plant?
No, I don't know!
I told Christine, what can I do?
What do you want me to do?
Whatever you want me
to do, I'll do it.